[Music]
congratulations on your show thanks very
funny and so much to talk about you have
pulled this show and I think you worked
on this show if I'm if I'm not mistaken
with your wife Samantha B is that you
guys co-created the show we co-created
that show and we co-created another show
on the network Oh full-frontal listen at
the beach yes we have two shows on a
spouse team and two TV shows yeah yes
well here's the thing you've clearly I
think pulled from your personal life
with a detour because you are it's about
a family on a road trip and it feels
like you're drawing from your experience
with them we listen we start everything
with conversations we've had with our
kids so one day our kids came up to us
and asked you know where do babies come
from and we told them maybe to
explicitly that's interesting you
decided to go with blunt truth because
we want to be the cool we don't want our
kids to hear from some dummy on the
playground we want to be the cool
parents who seem cool because we tell
them the consistency of semen so what
you know is it more like shampoo or is
it more like tahini sauce to which my
wife mistakenly said no it's saltier
which led to oh my god it led to a whole
new slew of questions yeah about always
good to gather the kids around and talk
wait your kids said what's the
consistency of semen Oh got to it what
the seeds look like well there where do
they come where does it come out of and
they wanted it obviously what does it
look like sure yeah it's come out and
yeah there you really went for it yeah
because I'm the cool dad yeah or the bad
dad effective you're the child services
dad
[Laughter]
you